Skål, Andrum.
Na
Ok, so I can pause and then talk more?
Yes, you can pause, yeah.
Use either the...
This one?
The space bar over there.
Ok.
And it will still work more as you're...
So here I was trying to hit that double sidekick and make sure that my stance lengths were right.
I think on this one I was a little bit iffy and then I was, like, noting that.
I knew I was going too fast here.
And I forgot the key up here and I was like, oh shoot, I forgot.
Yeah, I'm definitely going too fast.
And here I think was where I was the most, like, locked in.
Just remembering the sequences since I've done this so many times before.
I was trying to hit that sidekick height.
Yep.
And then getting the five second count on this move.
And then going to the back, making sure I got the stance lengths.
I was thinking about, like, how much my feet were sliding on the mat.
And I was like, that should not be happening.
But I was going, like, too fast to really fix it.
Yeah.
Question on how you scored.
So as you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10.
So out of 10.
Okay, so we're going to do this a second time
and I'm going to show you what we see here.
Now, we can't talk about
what happens when you want to score to a certain number,
which is very important, because if you're not calm then you're not going to make it
as easy as you might want to be.
if you're not calm then you probably won't make it as easy as you might even want to you thought yourself.